c'est à la mi journée jean christophe
mitterrand a quitté la prison de la
santé où il était incarcéré depuis le 21
décembre dernier sa mère madame danielle
mitterrand avait payé la caution de 5
millions de francs exigés par la justice
mais madame mitterrand a précisé
j'ai remis la somme pour payer la rançon
livre jean christophe mitterrand a
accordé à jeanne assouly marie pierre
farkas et raymond châtelard un entretien
exclusif
première image celle d'une mère qui
retrouve son fils après trois semaines
de prison
retrouvailles en famille et les premiers
mots ceux d'un homme en colère qui
refuse de dire qu'il est content content
content de quoi content d'être allé en
prison alors que j'aurais pas dû y être
content d'avoir à payer une caution
énorme à justifier pourquoi il avait
peur que je fuis nom de ça je peux pas
être content si jean christophe
mitterrand a finalement accepté de
suivre le conseil de ses avocats est
d'être libéré aujourd'hui c'est parce
qu'il veut se défendre
c'est avec son accord que danielle
mitterrand a réuni les 5 millions
réclamés par la justice
une somme que l'ancienne première dame
de france se refuse à qualifier de
caution
pour payer la rançon
la fuite de la famille sa remise en
liberté n'ont pas tempéré ses
accusations contre le juge courroye
comment voulez vous quand vous voyez un
juge qui sut la plaine avant d'ouvrir la
bouche
comment voulez vous ne pas comprendre
que immédiatement vous allez être
embastillé
mais dès que je suis entré dans le
bureau où il m'a mis en examen et il a
donné les les titres les raisons de me
mettre en examen les deux principales
étaient complicité de trafic d'armes et
trafic d'influencé
j'ai un jamais été question pendant 12
heures d'entretien avec la police jamais
une question m'a été posée à ce sujet la
tombée des nues j'ai l'impression que
j'ai été face aux juges parce que
j'étais dans un carnet d'adressés du
comment ça va intéresser lourdement la
justice vous avez pas pensé qu'on vous
demanderais d'être entendu comme témoin
la seule chose que tu m'avais dit à ce
sujet là c'est qu'ils avaient des des
problèmes et les impôts rien de plus
rien plus et vous n'êtes pas méfiée vous
êtes palier on va venir au joueur quoi
je me serais méfié de quoi de quoi mes
relations avec et qu'à chaque hall était
parfaitement saine pour vous c'est quoi
comment j'étais un homme d'affaires
intelligent et a séduit pas dans les
domaines dont on parle et non c'est on
parle maintenant vous êtes rencontrés
comment pour les deux violons et allons
tous 81,4 la danse mais bon je veux
pouvoir me défendre et j'ai des choses à
dire
au delà des accusations et des mises en
cause viendra le moment d'évoquer le
fond du dossier
et pour cela jean christophe mitterrand
va de nouveau faire face aux questions
du juge courroye